[Music]
imagine a virtual world that mirrors our
own
in it you meet colleagues
travel to foreign cities and even get
your pilot's license
this world is coming and you've probably
heard of it
it's called
the metaverse would allow that virtual
space to operate like the real world
does for everyone at the same time with
infinite memory and history
but if you thought the metaverse was all
about gaming gigs and virtual meetings
think again
it could transform numerous aspects of
our daily lives
heat is unbelievable from firefighting
and filmmaking we're going to see people
spending more time in immersive
experiences to manufacturing and
Medicine using augmented reality and
there's an opportunity for us to to do
things better
a whole new world is emerging and with
it multi-trillion dollar opportunities
you think the web transformed Our Lives
the 3D world is going to do much more
foreign
[Music]
s that we've created at ilm is what we
call stagecraft the stagecraft LED wall
which is this immersive environment
which filmmakers can use to create their
Productions
industrial Light and Magic is a
groundbreaking visual effects company
famous for recent shows like Disney's
Obi-Wan Kenobi
where is he
in the past it would have taken an army
of set design as months to build a set
like this
now with ilm's stagecraft technology set
can be designed virtually
revolutionizing the production process
stagecraft is ilm's virtual production
toolkit and it's really an end-to-end
solution so what you see on that led
wall is actually what goes straight into
the show this is the technology which
underpins the metaverse the ability to
conjure up realistic computer-generated
worlds in real time
but what exactly is the metaverse
ask a lot of people and some might tell
you it's about nfts
or donning a VR headset and jumping into
an online world like the game Second
Life
but for companies and professionals
working in the field the metaverse is
something far more significant
Matthew ball is a leading Authority on
the metaverse
for some it is a future state of today's
internet but which operates in a more
decentralized fashion but for most
especially those which operate big Tech
today they imagine it as a parallel
plane of existence a 3D virtual
simulacra of the Earth but with many
fictional elements allowing us to do
what is not possible
the term metaverse was first coined in
Neil Stevenson's 1992 novel snow crash
[Music]
but the metaverse has its roots in the
early gaming industry of the 1970s the
player can improve the machine's ability
by revising its program for decades the
video game industry has been developing
software and Hardware to create
simulations
initially these were very limited
these experiences began with
multi-user-shared hallucinations with
your own rules for real-time
collaboration with others to choose and
tell your own story but of course it
unfolded purely in text largely without
color
in the decades that followed we saw
persistent improvements in visual
Fidelity in the number of people who
engaged in these worlds their cultural
impact as well as their economic value
the Advent of 3D Graphics technology
transformed video games and fueled the
growth of the gaming industry
worth 13 billion in 1997 this Rose to
214 billion dollars in 2021
today this technology has come of age
Graphics software can now create a
simulated world's rules logic and
physics
it's already opening up New Frontiers
for creativity in the film and
television industry
thank you and background action
[Music]
I'm able to put actors and cameras in
this environment and we can see it and
play in it and live in it
ilm's film set was originally powered by
unreal a 3D computer Graphics engine
built by epic games one of the world's
largest game makers
ilm has since developed its own
real-time cinematic render engine called
Helios
and some of the biggest names in the
movie business are buying into it we
could actually get in-camera finished
visual effects that would really help us
with the quick turnaround that
television requires
so the first time we got to create and
use stagecraft was for John favreau's
show the Mandalorian and he really
wanted to advance the state of the art
even though it was going to be a TV show
he wanted it to feel like the movies
this new technology can also make the
business of Film Production more
efficient we've done an analysis and
about half the shots we shoot they just
go straight into the show now the other
half sometimes they need touch-ups or
fixes so have to work still needs to be
done in post but when you're talking
about thousands of shots that can be a
pretty significant streamlining and
reduction in that post-production
process
foreign
the vast opportunities emerging with
metaverse Technologies are drawing the
interest of some of the world's biggest
companies
Facebook is so excited it's changed its
name our company is now meta
hey oh hey Mark hey what's going on
and meta spent 10 billion dollars on
metaverse related Technologies in 2021
alone
and in January 2022 Microsoft announced
it would buy Activision Blizzard a
gaming company for 69 billion dollars to
strengthen its position in this emerging
market
in the first five months of 2022 private
Equity firms Venture capitalists and
corporations invested over 120 billion
dollars in the metaverse more than
double the total in 2021
but it's not only Tech Giants and big
corporations that are set to profit from
the metaverse
it offers Financial opportunities for
small would-be entrepreneurs wherever
they are on the planet
sometimes in places you might not expect
you don't have to be in San Francisco
yeah go to program computer games Simon
Burgess and Max Entwistle are two
developers who create virtual
experiences on the platform Roblox
is a huge online virtual world with
hundreds of thousands of different
experiences for players to explore meet
other people and role play
[Music]
Roblox which was launched in 2006 had 58
and a half million daily active users in
July 2022
at the end of that month it was valued
at 25 billion dollars
there are more than 11 and a half
million people developing games for
Roblox Max and Simon are two of the more
successful ones
we met in about 2010 I think both as
children we found each other in like a
game on Roblox and just became friends
through that basically
their game shark bite developed using
the free tools the platform provides has
now been played over a hundred million
times
and it Nets these recent graduates an
income of around 1 million dollars a
year I remember I was on the plane to
Frankfurt in Germany at the time
um and I just saw the numbers in the
game and getting up and up seeing more
players joining the game and I was just
absolutely awe it's completely
redirected my life before I joined
Roblox I never wanted to be a game
developer I didn't think it could be
possible
the shark's currently taking out the
back of the boat
yeah yeah quick
I got you
Roblox has its own currency called Robux
which users can buy with real money
[Music]
it may look like simple games with retro
style graphics
but this platform is a torch Bearer for
the metaverse
its creators promise Ultra immersive
virtual experiences that digitally
mirror those in the real world
many people think Roblox is a gaming
company we're not we are a technology
platform that allows for people of all
ages to be able to create and develop
experiences born out of their own
imagination
and publish it out on our platform and
then we share it out with Millions
The Experience itself is
we imagine the metaphors to be tens of
millions of different interconnected
Virtual Worlds all seamlessly integrated
with who you are how you communicate
your payment systems your virtual
purchases
the metaverse is already second nature
for children across the world
three out of four Americans age between
9 and 12 use roadblocks
as the half of 10 year olds in Britain
with that kind of popularity the
platform has caught the attention of
major Global brands
we never say exactly this is when a
technology went mainstream or
proliferated but at least for Generation
Z and Alpha it certainly appears to be
the metaverse has found its place in the
cultural Zeitgeist even if nobody knows
what its final state will look like
I feel like you could ask a million
developers what the net of this is and
everyone have a different definition
we're still coming to grasp the concept
of it and that um it's got a long way to
go only a very small portion of the
canvas has been painted so far
the metaverse is starting to offer
opportunities to a multitude of
Industries and new ways to tackle
pressing even deadly challenges
into chaos
oh foreign
looking plane has some extraordinary
technology on board developed by
Lockheed Martin as it flies above the
Colorado mountains the plane is
digitally mapping the wildfires that
rage below and it's changing how these
types of fires are fought
Lockheed Martin recognizes the impact
that wildfires in particular are having
on our lives on our economies and on the
climate there are helicopters coming in
and planes dropping water every few
minutes
so the capability that we're maturing is
called cognitive Mission manager or CMM
as the fire is spreading we're able to
apply artificial intelligence to predict
the firefront behavior and our goal is
to have a 3D visualization available to
those decision makers to those folks
that are deciding how to suppress the
fire so they can do so quickly and
efficiently
the project uses nvidia's Omniverse
platform
it's a tool that can create a precise
digital version of something that exists
in the real world known as a digital
twin
digital twins are a true to reality
simulation of a virtual environment to
the physical environment you can think
of it as two parts of a journey the
creation of things whether they're
buildings factories products scenarios
World Etc and then the operation of
those things in a digital twin concept
the way to think of it really is kind of
like the operating system for the
metaverse
Nvidia was founded in 1993 and for the
first 20 years made the tech that helped
Usher in the 3D Revolution in gaming
its microchips are suited to powering
the hardware and software needed to
create the increasingly sophisticated
simulations of the metaverse
as a result nvidia's chips are up this
will be the first one trillion dollar
semiconductor uh company
value increased increased just under 18
billion dollars in January 2016 to just
over 454 billion dollars in July 2022
with revenues growing by nearly 536
percent
[Music]
now building Earth 2 a supercomputer
that is creating a digital twin of the
weather across the planet
the ability to predict the climate
decades in advance could be crucial in
adapting to the impacts of climate
change
but that's only just the start
the metaverse is also set to transform
manufacturing across a range of
Industries Amazon Siemens and BMW are
among the big companies that are using
digital twin Technologies to recreate
their processes down to the smallest
detail
the factory of the future is going to be
more efficient it's going to be safer
it's going to be higher degree of
productivity
you can understand how Parts need to
come in and be moved around you can do
other things like training the robots in
those virtual factories before you
commit to them in the physical sense
we're starting to see digital twins not
just of a single environment but
multiple environments large-scale
environments Daisy chained together in a
simulation creating a digital twin not
just of a thing or a place but space
itself
but there is a potential problem as yet
the metaverse lacks an agreed standard
for connecting multiple Virtual Worlds
[Music]
something like the HTML protocol an
agreed standard that defines the
appearance and behavior of pages on the
web
when we think about the metaverse as a
3D elevation of the internet we require
the same sorts of structures new
standards for 3D information new
hierarchies that allow one virtual world
to know that another exists to then
communicate and safely securely and
consistently share information
but almost none of that exists today
the race is on to develop the metaverse
equivalent of HTML
thing that makes the metaverse so
impactful for everyone is the seamless
ability to go from virtual world to
Virtual World in much the same way today
we go from website to website doesn't
matter the device the browser Etc
once again it's Hollywood that is making
the running
Pixar needed a way for its animators to
collaborate effectively despite working
in different Studios and often with
different tools
so it developed its own software called
Universal scene description or USD
in 2016 USD was made open source free
for anyone to use
it's still early stages and it remains
to be seen where the USD will become the
universal protocol of the metaverse we
saw this as the potential to be the HTML
of 3D as we move forward into a 3D
Centric web so now everybody has a
common way of describing their 3D
environment and you know companies are
working together to advance the format
like we did with HTML
foreign
as some companies focus on wiring up the
metaverse others are busy developing
devices to access it and turns science
fiction into real commercial opportunity
there's nowhere left to go
except the Oasis
headsets which can superimpose
computer-generated imagery on the real
world so-called augmented reality are
opening ever more diverse applications
for the metaverse
we've got an exclusive look at one of
the military's latest Investments it's a
futuristic combat goggles that give
soldiers a brand new way to see the
battlefield in 2020 Microsoft agreed to
supply the U.S military with ar
technology in a deal that could be worth
22 billion dollars over 10 years
not only can soldiers see in the dark
but they can see through smoke and even
Peak around corners new extended or
mixed reality devices are essential to
some functions enriching our experience
in the metaverse and bringing it into
more forms
augmented reality devices are enabling
metaverse Technologies to make a real
difference to how vital services such as
Medical Care are delivered this is our
consent form for the procedure
here at Johnson Hopkins University in
America using AR devices in surgery is
rapidly becoming routine we're going to
be using a new augmented reality guided
computer system that's mounted on a
headset
Professor Tim Witham is a pioneering
surgeon who now uses augmented reality
to help perform spinal surgery
the the first procedure that we
performed with this technology involved
a woman in her 70s who had been
suffering for years from low back pain
during the surgery a marker is inserted
into the patient's spine
a CAT scan then creates an image of the
spine in relation to the marker the data
is then transferred to the augmented
reality headset while I'm looking inside
of the patient and putting the screw in
I see a heads up display that has the
computerized image that shows exactly
where the screw is going it's almost
like a GPS system
[Music]
the augmented reality allows Professor
Witham to perform the surgery with a
consistent accuracy that was previously
hard to achieve I've subsequently done
about 100 cases and we published data on
our accuracy or success rate if you will
and we've found that the device is about
98 accurate in the placement of spinal
instrumentation or implants into the
spine it was very rewarding to be able
to see the development of this new
technology and then be able to utilize
it uh in real clinical use
[Music]
the metaverse is already starting to
offer glimpses of its potential to drive
change and to shape how we behave in
profound ways
I find it very hard to predict what the
real Market opportunity will be the the
one thing that I know for sure is that
these new technologies will lead to new
behaviors and those new behaviors will
unlock markets that I can't predict
but as the metaverse grows so do the
challenges
Intel estimates that we need a nearly
thousand Factor Improvement in average
computing power plus Myriad more
Computing devices to begin with
and for all its promise to transform how
companies and people operate the
metaverse is likely to share the
pitfalls of the real world
one thing seems certain the idea that
the real world is limited to what is
physically present nearby will see an
increasingly bizarre I like to talk
about the metaverse as more than just a
tech wave but a societal one a
multi-trillion dollar Economic
Opportunity that will transform nearly
every country industry and person's life
global
hello I'm Tom standage Deputy editor at
The Economist if you'd like to learn
more about this topic click on the link
opposite and if you'd like to watch more
of our now and next series click on the
other link thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe